welcome to this video playing endless
fighter this is a GM but he's got no
name he changed flex quite often he had
a Bangladesh flag at one point if I
remember yeah ok it's fun four wins
eight losses so why we never played a
draw always always some yeah big fight
so is playing the classical Dutch yeah
this is an opening where I really don't
have any recipe against i'm playing with
be formed just because yeah i don't know
don't know a good a good reply it's one
of those openings that have that does
not have a good reputation but is in
fact not so bad not not at all I mean it
is not great but it is so it is very
very tricky and there is no nothing like
an obvious refutation or anything like
that a clear indication that there is no
such thing as that Grandmaster Simon
Williams is playing it against basically
anybody and I mean like if he plays
against someone with preparation even
and so they know that they're going to
face it and he's playing it and normally
with good results he has beaten word
word class grandmasters with this
opening the highest-rated being Boris
Gelfand the former World Championship
Challenger from Israel so this is an
opening that that needs to be taken
somewhat serious okay um how do I play
that my night on d 2 is not really great
maybe I can activate with Bishop c5
there should be six those ideas Quincy
to maybe Quincy to don't know
very unconventional position Bishop c5
to be six might also be an idea still
live ok so he actually allows the
strayed c5 is known right now that that
doesn't make any sense actually so maybe
i can double here I don't know maybe I
should have gone to see three with the
Queen tough but I don't want to fall too
far behind you clockwise trying to play
quickly
it's difficult though to do something
concrete against this night I cannot
really a Tekkit I wonder if f4 is a move
a form trading stuff on there on the
other side of the board
hmm whenever I move my D tonight is his
knife get square so maybe I still want
to have that here so that I have the
night attacked let's see if I can go
from here Queen before maybe I know it
takes interesting I because after this
she taking on a three really maybe
now Bishop b5 but still I've got Quincy
to and then pick up your form I can pick
up your phone
a force also also potentially week
he's got a ton of weak pawns almost all
of them but he's got 11 more I think one
extra bone and some not to be forgotten
and he's got a free see porn this is can
be a key a key factor he wants to play
b5 him but it's okay take stakes be five
rupee one would be a drug takes e4 is an
important tactic you can start with B
five maybe no it's not so if I'm taken I
can give the check and play fo actually
check
King edge 785 is check so this should
win material right or not how is he
saving himself that way is saving a
split bishop so rook be one or should I
take first hmm this is this one first I
guess check check and now is there a way
to get get to his king queen here i am
to attack age six and then maybe queen
III approaching approaching the king
position rookie six maybe a move Queen
f3f seven though
okay i know i came of culture f3 of
course not 630-7 the sea porn is kind of
can be a problem
I do know that was the best solution
takes takes the esco droop c6 so I have
to go here first and only then possibly
Roxy five go here approach with the King
time-bar see to look see three ok but I
can always play ok five
d for kinky too well a very tough tough
business but every I don't see at the
moment how i'm getting at the pawn this
is the real problem i'm not getting to
the pawn check I know we can just go
work T 10 know how idiotic was that okay
I am let's time blundering away this
position in one in one go yeah I mean I
probably have no realistic winning
chances but I mean losing is kind of
impossible unless you try too hard to
win yeah and so why did I spoil this him
so i should actually take on g60 I
wasn't sure I wasn't sure well it's I
kind of overlooked Queenie 6 also check
so what is the daughter should do h4 and
white wins okay I didn't see it Queen d2
snow yeah this is not much strong i have
the brook dominating on the phone rang
so this is where what I should have done
yeah twin c2 is against wrong yeah here
Queenie 6 is saving this was also strong
well that's expect very easy here here
why this is dominating you or maybe I
can even move the rook somewhere like
here I look she salmon and came add to
that defense
yeah but here I'm winning winning the
pawn but it's probably it's never enough
to win the game because of the strong
counter play but I wanted too much here
try and trying to win jack now this is
this is very simple i have to go here
but he has the check check for and this
and then rook to e1 so he was winning
here anyway I cannot approach with the
king must be content with were simpler
stuff yeah I mean if I just want to draw
i can i can just do that one of course
just return return the pawn and and then
this is this is a very simple draw but i
wanted more which was wrong here and it
was just too too ambitious kind of
influenced by the fact that I was
thinking that I should should be much
better here which which was true but
with other with other means I also could
have taken here maybe this is what I
should have done in the first place this
kind of thing yeah but ok the other one
was good i just have to play deform
which I did not see at all ok thanks for
watching